ja fast 100 Tage Krieg in der Ukraine
und dieser geht blutig weiter im Osten
des Landes wir wollen uns verschiedene
Szenen der letzten Tage ansehen wie dort
gekämpft wird wo dort gekämpft wird und
was das für den gesamten Krieg bedeutet
wir gehen uns mal die Lage im Osten
ansehen zum einen wollen wir hier oben
hingucken in die Region rakiv dort ist
den Ukraine ja ein eine Gegenoffensive
gelungen dort konnte mittlerweile sogar
der Präsident wieder sich in die Stadt
wagen wenn auch unter großen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen aber hier weiter
im Süden unten in den Regionen luansk
und dann jetzt dort ist die Lage für die
Ukrainer ja man möchte sagen angespannt
aber im Grunde katastrophal in einigen
Gegnern die letzte große Stadt sie vero
Donezk das ist die Stadt die dort
gehalten wird in in luhansk diese wird
seit zwei Tagen angegriffen und wir
wissen heute morgen das russische
Truppen hier vorgedrungen sind dass sie
in der Stadt sind dass sie Teile besetzt
haben das heißt nicht nur schließt sich
dieser Kessel von dem wir immer
gesprochen haben hier sondern auch von
vorne sozusagen also frontal wird sie
während du Netz angegriffen und die
Ukraine haben sich teilweise aus einigen
Teilen der Stadt zurückgezogen wir
wollen uns als allererstes ein Video aus
hakiv ansehen denn ein hakiv wissen wir
da ist eben diese Gegenoffensive relativ
erfolgreich da gibt es diese ja nur noch
kleine Dörfer sozusagen die von den
Russen gehalten werden und hier sehen
wir interessanterweise man hört das
vielleicht englisch sprechend das ist
die Fremdenlegion das sind also
ausländische Freiwillige die für ganz
normalen sollte der ukrainischen Armee
der ist relativ gering hier in die
Ukraine gegangen sind und jetzt gerade
zu zweit bzw zu zweit aber zwei von
ihnen greifen ein russisches gepanzertes
Fahrzeug an und was ganz spannend ist
wir haben eben gesehen dieser eine
Soldat hier halt eine tschechische
Panzerfaust der ist zum zum Schutz nur
da sollte zurückgeschossen werden der
andere Soldat nämlich der der hier filmt
hat eine deutsche Panzerfaust eine RGB
90 Matador und wir sehen jetzt gleich
das ist der der jetzt gleich schießt
hier vorne ist sie zu sehen wir sehen
jetzt wieder da vorne auf ein BTR 80 der
russischen Armee schießt und dieses dann
auch trifft und schwer beschädigt
das ganze wird hier nicht nur aus dieser
Helmkamera festgehalten sondern
interessanterweise auch aus einer Drohne
das heißt die Ukraine wieder oder diese
Fremdenlegion in dem Fall hat wieder das
ganze überwacht aus einer Drohne und wir
sehen mal wie nah das ist hier vorne das
Mündungsfeuer hier vorne der Einschlag
das sind vielleicht 200 m oder so über
die eben hier geschossen wird so nah ist
die fremdenlegionen mit amerikanischen
mit kanadischen mit australischen mit
polnischen wir hören auch mit deutschen
Freiwilligen hier nur entfernt von dem
Fahrzeug von der von den Russen und das
ist dann schwer beschädigt kann sich
dann auch in den Wald zurück retten wir
sehen es jetzt hier wie es raus
rausfährt aus dieser Wolke aber im Wald
sieht man dann gleich noch mal von oben
wie die Munition weiter explodiert auf
dem BTR 80 das heißt zumindest die
Hauptwaffe ist hier nicht mehr zu
benutzen wir sehen auch hier vorne wie
alle Klappen offen sind also da ist
höchstwahrscheinlich die Besatzung
rausgegangen und zu guter Letzt sehen
wir auch wie diese Fremdenlegion sich
dann wieder durch den Wald zurückzieht
das sind kleine Teams ja kill Teams
sozusagen die losgeschickt werden in den
Wald um einzelnen russischen
zurückgebliebenen oder Spänen
Schützenpanzern aufzulauern und diese zu
vernichten das hat in dem Fall hier ganz
gut geklappt wir müssen uns aber auch
ansehen wie die Region wie es in Donezk
aussieht und hier sehen wir eine völlig
zerstörte Stadt wir sehen mal wieder
diese große eine Straße sozusagen links
und rechts die völlig zerstörten Häuser
und wir sehen wie die ukrainische
Artillerie hier gegen russische
Fahrzeuge vorgeht da sehen wir ein BTR
in sorry ein BMP2 der russischen Armee
auch das ein Schützenpanzer genauso ein
Schützenpanzer wie die Ukraine in
bräuchte wie sie auch von Deutschland
bräuchte aber bisher nicht bekommt und
der wird hier vernichtet von der
ukrainischen Artillerie man sieht aber
auch und da muss man sich auch ehrlich
machen wie links und rechts davon die
Geschosse einschlagen das heißt wir
haben es hier nicht mit
hochleistungspräzisionsartillerie zu tun
sondern dass es tatsächlich Artillerie
die ja die Russen ausschaltet aber aber
auch von der zivilen Infrastruktur links
und rechts nichts davon übrig lässt das
ist der Preis dieses Krieges den Putin
über über das Land gebracht hat wir
sehen hier wieder wie links und rechts
sozusagen die Einschläge sind und jetzt
das BMP völlig explodiert das heißt die
Russen die darin waren sind dann in dem
Fall tot aber eben Kosten sozusagen ist
die Infrastruktur links und rechts die
zivilen Häuser die natürlich vorher
verlassen wurden aber dann auch ja
völlig unnutzbar sind und zu guter Letzt
was heißt zu guter Letzt zu schlimmer
Letzt müssen wir uns noch ansehen was
ich finde wirklich sinnbildlich ist für
den Krieg in der Ukraine gerade im Osten
des Landes wir sehen ganz kurz am Anfang
markiert eine Flaggen wie hier etwa 10
russische Soldaten auf der Seite durch
einen Schützengraben vorrücken das ist
wirklich so wie wie man es ja vielleicht
weil der Soldat James Ryan oder so kennt
diese Schützengräben in der Nähe von
afdiefka soll das sein in Donuts die
jahrelang gebaut wurden gegraben wurden
von den Ukrainern um sich zu verteidigen
aber auch die werden langsam nach und
nach gestürmt und unfassbare Aufnahmen
wir sehen jetzt gleich wie ein einzelner
ukrainischer ich werde ihn einmal
markieren ein einzelner ukrainischer
Soldat sich hier verteidigt gegen die
anrückenden Russen die sind alle hier zu
sehen und wir sehen wie er wirklich
macht was er kann wie er damit seinem
Gewehr schießt und wie er dann aber
immer mehr unter Druck gerät wie die
Russen ihn angreifen wie die mit
Granaten werfen wir sehen das hier unten
gleich mal wie diese Granaten losfliegen
und auf ihn geworfen werden und er
versucht sich wie gesagt da weiter zu
wehren das Ganze mündet leider in der
Katastrophe es mündet so wie immer immer
öfter in den letzten Tagen die Russen
gewinnen diese Schlacht die Russen
schaffen es irgendwann den Ukrainer mit
immer mehr Granaten dieser auf ihn
werfen einige kann er noch zurückwerfen
andere nicht mehr dann auch zu töten
aber und das finde ich ganz spannend
oder was heißt spannend dass wir ist
einfach sinnbildlich für diesen Krieg
die Ukraine geben nicht auf auch gegen
die absolute Übermacht von Russen
verteidigt sich dieser Mann hier weiter
versucht also immer wieder die Granaten
die auf ihn geworfen werden
zurückzuwerfen
bis es dann irgendwann nicht mehr geht
und die russischen Invasoren dann auch
seinen Teil dieses Schützengrabens hier
einnimmt das also wie ich finde
sinnbildlich für den Krieg im Osten der
Ukraine wo die Ukraine mit allem was sie
haben Widerstand leisten und wirklich
versuchen diese Offensive zu beenden
aber bislang fehlen ihnen weiterhin die
Hightech Waffen in vielen die schweren
Waffen aus dem besten vor allem aus
Deutschland und aus diesem Grunde ist es
leider so im Osten der Ukraine in Don
Bass das hier Putins Truppen weiter
vorrücken